[Music]
president Trump emerged into the
courtyard of the Alizee palace having
already and intentionally stirred things
up he's here at the invitation of his
French counterpart who's hosting a
weekend of reflection on the centenary
of the end of World War one but behind
the pomp and the smiles was the fallout
from a trademark Trump tweet sent about
his host just as he'd arrived president
macron of France has just suggested that
Europe builds its own military in order
to protect itself from the US China and
Russia very insulting but perhaps Europe
should first pay its fair share of NATO
which the u.s. subsidizes greatly still
mr. mackrel hadn't actually suggested
that the US posed a military threat to
Europe just that it was no longer a
partner Europe could rely on together
face to face they were rather more
diplomatic the United States can only do
so much in fairness to the United States
that's why I do believe that we need
more European capacities more European
defense what Britain threnody has to
protect all to defend one of the job one
of the state of the United States it
doesn't ask France or Germany or another
government of Europe to finance it
that's why I do believe that we need
more investment it's exactly what we do
in France it's the first increase in
terms of budgets for defense for the
coming years who will reach the top
percent but that's why I do believe that
we need more the body language was a
little awkward but the private lunch
with the first lady's lasted over two
hours we can only assume that they did
discuss the disagreements over defense
trade and values in general well the
meeting was we're told constructive the
tweet was part of a misunderstanding and
according to mr. Trump the two sides are
closer than people might expect but
European leaders are now working on the
assumption that this trump presidency is
not a four-year flash-in-the-pan
the midterm suggests
he may well win a second four-year term
by afternoon mister macron had joined
the German Chancellor outside Paris at
the spot where signatures brought World
War one to an end a hundred years ago
mrs. Merkel and mr. macarons signed the
visitors book in a replica of a train
carriage where the armistice was signed
on November the 11th 1918 a Centurion
reflecting on an enormous loss at the
Tomb of the Unknown Soldier in the heart
of the French capital the final
preparations are being made for the
mourning ceremony 81 heads of state and
leaders of international institutions
will be here it will be a reflection on
the past but a contemplation too perhaps
on the future at an uncertain time mark
stone Sky News in Paris